c'est la méga fête danis de mes 29 c'est
toujours des trucs de malade là je
trouve que c'est toute la ville qui
comprend 10 paris aux portes des
quarts on se délie j'arrive
on redémarre en position étoiles de mer
et mes toiles ça vole bas
[Musique]
j'avais quatre questions pour mes 40 80
je suis trop content d'avoir discuté
avec toi on se capte bientôt ok allez
dites au revoir
les enfants dites à votre mère que vous
allez vous débrouiller sans moi pour
être honnête j'y mets quelques doutes
des olives le monde mais c'est là bas
qu'il y ait cette semaine son père aura
du temps libre
je fais m'offrir du temps libre temps au
temps mon temps
ouais c'est mon temps
et heure
optison écoute juré que ce sera la
meilleure semaine de toute la mine
où sont les toilettes juste la partie
une pile de sautant prend 1 tu puisses
tu l'as tu le vis de son bord de la
route je te laisse te débrouiller
pourquoi tu veux réduire enfin le
campement ont fait construire une
immense statue à son effigie alors que
tu me doit un paquet
[Musique]
passage que personne ne panique mais
bakker